course we have children
and in those individuals we don't know
the effects of long covered for example
and secondly some of them do become
seriously ill and some of them are dying
looking at what's happening over in
europe are you concerned
i think europe is is at a different
stage of the the epidemic they
potentially have had surges later than
us because they have maintained
social distancing and masking throughout
the summer and autumn periods
and therefore have uh sort of staved off
the increase in infections now they are
experiencing increases but their numbers
are not in the in the sort of all part
of hours per capita and secondly they're
not experiencing the mortality that we
have seen so
their increases should be taken into
perspective from what's happened in this
country which is rather devastating from
my point of view
okay i can just
let our viewers know and you as well so
that um we're being told that the
vaccinations the boosters will be in in
play for the over 40s that's what we're
expecting the announcement uh to be in
just a moment from today is what we're
being told your initial reaction to that
literally just heard that news
very welcome of course um but as i was
saying earlier
uh people in the older age groups have
still not fully been been fully
vaccinated and some are finding it
difficult to get appointments so yes
it's fantastic to see it um uh going
down the age groups and i believe in the
longer term the coroner's worst
vaccination will be a three dose regimen
as we go forward um
and this is the start of that so so it's
very welcome that boosters are being
emphasized but as i said there are huge
chunks of younger individuals who um are
the places where transmission is
happening and it's feeding into
vulnerable people in the older age
groups
okay also hearing that second doses will
now be available for 16 and 17 year olds
professor
fantastic yes um many of us were
concerned at the fact that a single dose
would be administered um because of
course the data on efficacy are all
about two doses so we're i'm really
pleased that it's two doses i must
interrupt you i'm so sorry because let's
hear now from number 10. thank you for
your time
good morning colleagues and welcome to
this morning's downing street briefing
which is a technical briefing on the
kovid 19 vaccination programme
i'm jonathan vantam deputy chief medical
officer i'm joining this morning from a
clinical area
and in the room you have uh dr june rain
chief executive officer of the mhra
and professor weishan lim chair of the
jcvi covid19 vaccine subcommittee
um without further ado i shall pass to
the first of uh our technical experts dr
rain to give an update from the
perspective of the mhra dr brain
thank you and good morning as the uk's
independent regulator for all medicines
vaccines and medical devices our role is
to ensure that the public have access to
safe and effective vaccines your safety
is always our top priority and we've
continued to proactively monitor the
safety of all kovid 19 vaccines since
the rollout began last year
our regulatory position remains that
covid19 vaccines available for use in
the uk have an overwhelmingly positive
benefit risk balance you can be
confident that covid19 vaccines for use
in the uk are very effective and
acceptably safe
since the booster doses began to be
rolled out in people aged 50 and over
from september we have identified no new
safety concerns
our careful review of the data at the
time of approval found that the booster
doses are effective our ongoing safety
monitoring has found the majority of
adverse effects to be mild to moderate
relating to reactogenicity such as a
sore arm or headache or tiredness
when you're called for your booster dose
in the next phase you can come forward
confident that the benefits in
preventing serious covert 19 far
outweigh any risks
turning to younger people aged 16 to 17
our regulatory position remains as when
we gave the first approval for use of
the fisa biontech vaccine in those over
the age of 16 in december 2020 that is
that this vaccine is safe and effective
in a two dose schedule
we've closely monitored the safety of
covid 19 vaccines in individuals under
18.
our review of reports of suspected side
effects does not raise any additional
safety issues specific to this age group
as is set out in our summary report
there have been a small number of
reports of suspected myocarditis heart
inflammation
associated with pfizer and moderna
vaccines in both the uk and
internationally this is a recognized
very rare potential risk with these two
vaccines
we're closely monitoring it and
importantly now that we have more
experience of use in the under 30s in
the uk we are not detecting any increase
in risk with the second dose so our
message is to people aged 16 and 17 it's
safe to have a second dose of the fisa
vaccine and if you're called for your
second vaccination please come forward
and this ensures that you're further
protected against covid19
just finally i'd like to take this
chance to thank everyone who has
reported suspected side effects
associated with covid19 vaccines please
continue to report via our coronavirus
yellow card by reporting you help
improve the safe use of vaccines for
everyone and it helps us as your
independent regulator to take action if
necessary safety is always and continues
to be our top priority
thank you jbt
uh thank you june um colleagues will
have an opportunity to ask dr rain any
questions they wish at the end of the
briefing
i'm turning now to professor lim wei
shen um to give us an update from the
jcvi which forms the main part of this
briefing
thank you very much
today gcvi is announcing
two updates to the vaccine program the
first update relates to the booster
program
could i have a first slide please
just as a reminder the current advice in
the booster program is that persons age
over 50 years
those adults in a clinical at risk group
frontline health and social care workers
and close contacts of persons who are
immunosuppressed
should have a booster vaccine six months
following completion of their primary
cause essentially have a third vaccine
dose six months after their second dose
you can have the next slide please
we're advising today that the
booster program is extended to persons
age 40 to 49 years as well
as previously the boosted dose is
advised six months after the second dose
and either the fisa beyond type vaccine
or the moderna vaccine can be used as
the booster dose regardless of the type
of vaccine received for the first two
doses in the primary course
i'd like to just mention the
dose used for the moderna booster
the dose used is 50 micrograms which is
half the dose used in the primary cause
which was a hundred or is a hundred
micrograms
this use of a lower dose
of vaccine for the boosted dose is a
recognized method of boosting
vaccine-induced immunity
it has been used for years and is
continuing to be used now in other
routine immunization programs such as
the booster doses used in against
diphtheria
tetanus and pertussis this is not an
unusual thing to do
a lower dose for the booster dose
is a very
usual method of boosting the immune
system
for the moderna vaccine we also know
that studies have been done
looking at the lower dose or half dose
booster dose of moderna and after the
third booster dose sorry after the third
dose which is a booster dose the immune
response is far higher than after the
second dose so we know that this half
dose as a booster works very well
the half dose of the booster dose is
also expected to be okay just fading out
of here for just a moment or two because
we want to bring you this image this
is what a hero looks like it would
appear that heroes don't always have to
wear capes this is david perry what he
did yesterday morning is still
filtering through will i'm sure be able
to give you more information later on in
the day but um though his cab was hailed
to take um his passenger to an area of
liverpool for whatever reason he seemed
to realize there was a problem he got
out of his cab and locked the passenger
in the cab there was then an explosion
the passenger was killed subsequently
three people have been arrested under
the terrorism act david was also injured
he was taken to hospital he has now been
released we believe but what an amazing
man he is this is what the government
said this morning
the contrast between the the cowardice
of uh terrorist attacks and the bravery
of ordinary britons up and down the
country who who put other people's lives
uh before their their own clearly will
have to see exactly what happened there
but if that that is the case that's
another example of of true bravery and
courage
sure is and this is him this is david
perry he is the taxi driver that was
injured outside the women's hospital in
liverpool yesterday the passenger that
detailed his cab
was locked inside we believe and the cab
exploded one person died the passenger
subsequently three people have been
arrested under the terrorism act in
areas of liverpool the kensington area
of liverpool david we're pleased to say
has now been released from hospital more
on that to come but let's take you back
to downing street now should we and uh
the latest on jabs for teenagers and
boosters for the
over 40s yeah covet 19
we said at the time that we would review
the data and anticipate that a second
dose may well be advised
that is indeed the case we have reviewed
the recent information regarding
the safety and the benefits of a second
dose and we are advising that
16 and 17 year olds who have had a first
dose of the fisa beyond that vaccine be
offered a second dose of the pfizer
beyond that vaccine
as a reminder the first vaccine dose
gives a high level of protection against
serious disease
and that high level of protection we
know lasts for at least 12 to 16 weeks
the second dose nonetheless reinforces
that protection from the first dose and
is important in extending the duration
of protection not just for the winter
months and christmas but we're also
looking into 2022 and beyond
there is
a question about the spacing and the
timing of the second dose compared to
the first dose
we are advising that the second dose is
given 12 weeks after the first dose
you may remember that at the very start
of the vaccine program in the uk
the jcbi advised that second doses of
vaccines be given 12 weeks which is an
extended interval after the first dose
we now have quite a lot of data to show
that the extended interval
increases the level of protection and by
doing so probably extends the level of
protection
we also have emerging data to show that
the extended interval between those one
and those two
also results probably in less adverse
reactions so there are overall benefits
in keeping an extended interval between
dose one and those two
therefore for 16 and 17 year olds we're
advising that the second dose is given
12 weeks or more after the first dose
in summary there are two updates we're
giving today
the first is for a booster dose for
persons
age 40 to 49 years old and a second dose
of the pfizer beyond that vaccine for 16
to 17 year olds
both of these updates are important to
maximize our protection against this
virus and i strongly average anyone who
is eligible for these vaccines to come
and have those vaccines thank you
thank you shen i am now just going to
make a few um overarching remarks
to follow our two technical experts
before we open for some questions
so
i think it is clear that we are now
moving at considerable pace um with the
booster program
the uk data show so far that in adults
aged over 60 after boosting with a
messenger rna vaccine that's isa pfizer
30 micrograms or moderna 50 micrograms
as weishan has explained
we're achieving well in excess of 90
protection against symptomatic infection
irrespective of which vaccine
people had as their primary course
and on the basis of those figures i
would therefore expect protection
against hospitalization and death to be
even higher
after boosting once we have the data
here in the uk
for now we look at the israeli data and
some key publications there
showing that in people aged over 60 in
israel after a messenger rna booster
and compared with simply having received
the first two doses of pfizer in there
in the case of israel three to four
weeks apart
they are observing a
tenfold reduction against all coveted
infections
and
18.7 fold reduction against
hospitalizations
and a 14.7 fold reduction against
mortality mortality and that's on top
of
the initial course of pfizer
so
i believe therefore that if the booster
program is successful
and with very high uptake
we can massively reduce the worry about
hospitalization and death due to covid
at christmas and for the rest of this
winter for literally millions of people
it really is as simple as decisive
as that
now jcvi is independent
and it is thorough it first showed its
independence when it advised on the
12-week interval
for vaccines at the beginning of the uk
program and at the time it was publicly
criticized for doing so by the british
medical association and the world health
organization
but the data now show that jcvi was
right
and many nations have now followed the
uk strategy
so um
whilst vaccines have fundamentally
changed the course of the pandemic in
the uk
and the high uptake of the initial
program has saved countless lives and
helped restore our freedoms in an
unprecedented way
it is also clear that protection will
wane over time
and uh that is after the first two doses
of a primary course and that's
especially so
in older adults and those with risk
conditions
and that explains why we've already made
the decisions we've made about the
booster program
but the waning signal whilst
smaller is also beginning to show
in the 40 to 49
and without boosting i would not expect
it to be static i would expect it to
increase
so jcvi has again acted decisively and
recommended that the booster program is
now extended to 40 to 49
on 16 to 17 year olds and the
announcement today of the second dose
confidence has grown with time that two
doses of the fisa vaccine is the right
choice for this age group
you've heard from dr rain that
confidence has also grown over safety
in particular the very low risks of
suspected myocarditis
compared with the long-term benefits
of a life without covet illness and
covid disruption
jcvi has used the data in an extra
safety step of adding in that 12 week
interval
for the second dose in 16 to 17 year
olds without risk conditions
i have full confidence in both of the
decisions that have been announced today
the uk expects
it to have enough supplies of vaccine to
implement these changes
the details of how to access the
boosters for these extra two layers of
protection will be announced in due
course by the nhs
but
in the meantime i would say it is still
a priority and a priority ordering for
the booster doses age is still the
biggest risk factor
um the elderly adults at risk and health
and social care workers remain the top
priority for boosters
and we should never have a case where 40
year olds without risk conditions are
vaccinated on mass
whilst many 60 and 70 year olds are
waiting for their boosters but the
natural timing
of when we implemented the initial
program
should mean that in the main there is a
natural ordering to the time at which
somebody becomes eligible for booster at
six months so i don't expect to this
this to be a significant problem
so the nhs is moving at real pace now
boosting 300 to 400 000 people
today per day but all of this will stay
still take some time to achieve
and i want to make another plea to
people who have not been vaccinated
or have only had one dose
it is now very clear indeed that one
dose is not enough of any of the uk
deployed vaccines and that no doses at
all massively increases the risk of
hospitalization
the latest uk health security agency
data
show that for
the age band 18 to 29
the rate of admission to hospital with
covid
is 1.4
per 100 000 if double vaccinated
but 7.8 per 100 000 if unvaccinated
which is five-fold higher
and for aged 30 to 39
those similar rates are 4.1 per 100 000
for the double vaccinated
and
17.3 per hundred thousand for the
unvaccinated which is four times higher
so
just to finally summarize the uk covert
program is evolving as the data
two
further evolutionary steps are announced
today okay so we will get more from
jonathan van tam and his colleagues
basically the headline is that uh over
16s will be offered their second dose
over 40s are being encouraged to have
their booster jumps more on that
throughout the course of the day here on
sky news meantime
ali is here we've seen the picture of
what everyone is calling a hero in
liverpool this morning that's right he's
been including the government yes that's
right we understand he's been named as
david perry this is a taxi driver that
was driving um the taxi when the
explosion happened in liverpool we know
of course that one person has died there
have been reports that he locked the
attacker inside the taxi he's been
called heroic oliver dowden
talked about the contrast between the
cowardice of the attackers he put it in
the bravery of ordinary people okay
let's see what he had to say let's have
a quick listen
the contrast between the the cowardice
of uh terrorist attacks and the bravery
of ordinary britons up and down the
country who who put other people's lives
uh before their their own clearly we'll
have to see exactly what happened there
but if that that is the case that's
another example of of true bravery and
courage
we've been hearing from the mayor of
liverpool as well this morning haven't
we there he is david perry what a hero
that's right yes we joanne anderson who
is the mayor of liverpool said that his
efforts were heroic as she put it and we
understand that he has been discharged
from hospital that he is recovering at
home and yet as you say there he is
david perry who
has been praised um by politicians from
across the house people uh across the
country for his heroic efforts during
that terrible attack yeah stand by if
you were because sadio is also with us
this morning she's standing by in
liverpool um the investigation three
people arrested so far sadie what more
do we know
yeah that's right okay three people have
been arrested but this morning some
activity taking place behind me were at
the scene of the blast at uh the
hospital
and a few details emerging about the
taxi driver there uh today someone who
describes himself as a friend of his
told us that he's now home from hospital
and with his family
and as you say three arrests were made
at a property uh yesterday that property
was still cordoned off this morning when
i went there cordons are still also
around a separate property
at rutland avenue
that's expected to remain there for some
time and a few addresses there have been
evacuated police say as a precaution and
of course here recording remains at the
hospital where the blast took place
right around the front of the hospital
all the way up to grove street there on
the right
hey san diego thanks very much indeed um
ali this is going to obviously develop
throughout the course of the day
interesting that politicians were both
very keen the two that we had on this
morning very keen to praise um the
bravery of of this taxi driver david
perry as we know now that's right and we
expect an update from pretty patel the
home secretary later today do we okay
that's fantastic it's actually been
reflected in the papers this morning
that explosion in liverpool taking up
many of the front pages this morning
looking at a few of them for you here we
go
this is the telegraph saying one person
killed another injured in the incident
the daily mail also focusing on the car
explosion with three men arrested by
counter-terror police following the
incident and then looking at the times
reports that armed officers and
negotiators were sent to a property
in east liverpool as part of operations
so that's what the newspapers are saying
this morning it has now has been
established that the driver of that cab
who was taken to hospital after that
explosion at just before a minute to 11
yesterday morning was david
perry
um
and david has there he is
you'll see a lot of his picture in
tomorrow morning's papers i absolutely
guarantee it he has now been released
from hospital is what i'm being told as
as you know sadia
was updating us from liverpool the
kensington area of liverpool where three
people in their twenties were arrested
last night the police investigation is
continuing and we're hearing that there
will be a news conference from the
police either merseyside police or
indeed the terror group
in greater manchester police maybe a
joint uh police statement from the two
of them that is going to be happening at
11 o'clock this morning what i can tell
you is that three people in their 20s
have been arrested armed police had
defended on several streets in the
kensington area of liverpool a
vehicle a taxi had exploded just a
minute before 11 o'clock in the morning
yesterday morning the cab driver david
perry had managed to get out of that
vehicle we're told he'd managed to lock
the doors of the vehicle the vehicle
then subsequently exploded the mayor of
liverpool calling that man a hero this
morning stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
the top stories live from the sky news
city studio
virtual diplomacy u.s president joe
biden and china's leader xi jinping set
for talks with trade cyber security and
human rights all on the table
shel announces plans to ditch its dual
share structure and move its tax
residence from the netherlands to the uk
what are youtube's plans to protect the
well-being of its creators we'll be
hearing from its uk managing director
and we'll hear from the boss of the
french startup looking to take on excel
[Music]
good morning this is ian king live in
our business and economic news from the
heart of the city and the leaders of the
world's two largest economies will hold
talks later today u.s president joe
biden and president xi jinping of china
are set to meet virtually amid rising
tensions between the two countries it
follows the conclusion of the cop 26
climate summit in glasgow which ended
with a deal that many critics saw as a
failure well that was because of a late
intervention by china and india which
saw countries only agree to phase down
rather than phase out coal but it's not
the only issue dividing the u.s and
china as our asia correspondent tom
cheshire now explains
they've got a lot to talk about it they
disagree on pretty much every issue you
could think of the origins of covet 19
and investigating that on trade on the
south china sea on what looks like a
huge nuclear buildup by china then
xinjiang the treatment of the uyga
minority and other minorities there and
what's happening in hong kong and then i
think the biggest of all though what
both sides really want to try and